Fire kills whites you told me what breathes fire
Hey, YouTubers
Congratulations for surviving comic-con now. We got to freak out about episode two just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
I was surprised by how many times they referenced Aegon's conquest
And Robert's rebellion they keep doing that in each of the episode so it's probably going to keep happening to where they like in events
That are happening at present-day this very same thing played out before but if you're new to the channel
I'm doing game of thrones videos all season be sure to subscribe to get everything and there is a giveaway
I'll explain at the end of the video
but starting with number 10 stormborn so like they actually
Narrated in the early part of the episode Daenerys was born during the end of Robert's rebellion while a great storm was raging over
Dragonstone the most depressing side ever you come to your ancestral home, and it's the exact opposite whether from a sunny marine
But the interesting thing is it goes beyond that there are a lot more?
Parallels because during the night of that storm of her birth the targaryen fleet was being smashed in the eastern sea
So just like at the end of this episode the Greyjoy fleet that they had got smashed by Euron's fleet
So it's almost an exact repeat of the events of that night
But I love how daenerys starts to turn on her small council a little bit
It's just her way of letting them know that she has her eyes on them
She doesn't completely trust them even though she believes that they'll be loyal. I'll burn you alive otherwise
I love the nice hat tip for the mad king burning rickard stark which they later referred to during the jon
Snow's Storyline, remember what happened when our grandfather went to meet the targaryen king. They're still referring to jon
Snow as a stark because they don't know his heritage yet
It will talk about this again in a second
But he also said that Salsas the only stark in Winterfell
Like we know brands going to show up eventually to so there was a lot of eye winking in this episode for things that we
know they're setting up because the characters don't know yet the
queen of thorns also had a really nice moment with daenerys where she's like you're not a sheep like the rest of the lords of
Westeros, are you you're a dragon
So maybe you don't always listen to tyrion so I think what she's just trying to tell daenerys is not to use too much restraint
Margery was a wonderful person and now she's a pile of ashes, so we'll see
Happens when they actually go up against the Lannister army
I cannot wait to see what tyrion does when they're facing jaime and open battle because we haven't got to that yet
but number nine Melisandre shows up speaking high Valyrian
Explaining the prophecy of the prince who was promised and I love myths and I said actually you know, it's a gender-neutral
Prophecy which theory crafters like I've said on my channel pretty much anybody who's ever put a game of thrones prince was promised Theory on
The internet has pointed out the fact that it could be a man could be a woman based on the way the prophecy should be
Interpreted the way high Valyrian intended to be but she's just explaining to Daenerys who Jon. Snow is why he's so important
Let him come and tell you what he'd seen you need to form an alliance
But even though tyrion vouches for him which I did like like I trust him. I went to the wall with him
I think the reason why they added that line where daenerys is like
I'm going to make him bend the knee is because they don't want it to seem too
Easy Daenerys is sort of looking at her small Council with where he eyes
She's also doing the same thing with Jon snow
So it's not like they're going to all start hugging on site and embrace Jon is the secret targaryen they still don't know anything about?
His heritage Daenerys has barely just learned anything about the white walkers so number eight down in King's landing is tyrion predicts
exactly Cersei takes a very xenophobic
Approach in trying to turn the tyrell bannermen to her side they're going to come in with their dothraki Hordes burn
Pillage everything and raze it to the ground we need to unite against them so Jaime
Dangles the idea of becoming warden of the south in place of the tyrells once they defeat their army
The really cool thing about this interaction though the more fun scene was when Jaime started talking to them because he's like are you?
Rigored tarly and all of a sudden everyone's like ah triggered again another Rickard stark
Name-Drop special meaning for Jaime because he was there to witness
Rickard burning when the mad king set him on fire
And then it gets even better because randyll tarly
Throws the fact that Jaime's a kingslayer in his face the tarly name means something we don't stab people in the back
Which is the Kingslayer reference?
And we don't slit people's throats when we've invited them to dinner for a wedding
Which of course is a hat tip for the red wedding which the lannisters engineered?
They want to show you that he has principles like he's not a completely evil person
It'll be interesting to see what ends up happening when Samwell finds out that he's fighting for the opposition
Speaking of which cut to the citadel number seven we finally get into the surge Aura Plotline
I love the way the ebro's is reacting to all this like nope
He's incurable can't do anything about it the archmaester the thought of some secret techniques for deterring greyscale
What happened to him he died of greyscale? So there's nothing you can do about it?
so of course Samwell isn't going to listen to that he uses the archmaester special techniques and basically just cuts the
Greyscale off, and then it's going to treat it. It's going to involve some dragonglass treatment, so we haven't quite got to that
They'll follow up with it next week like you've done the first part now
You need to prevent it from coming back in the future the really extra bits that I loved about these scenes though
Is that Ebro's looks at Jorah Sword looks at him and says?
I'll give you one more night in case there's something you want to do so he's basically telling Jorah
I'm going to give you time to go out honorably so before Samwell comes in to cure him
He looks at the sword again as he's writing that letter to Daenerys like he's actually contemplating
Maybe I go out this way rather than die slowly, but I think of course we know that he's going to be cured
It's just going to be
incredibly painful and what about that transition
From like the puss and his wound to the man supo at the end of the crossroads
It's almost like Dan and dave are trying to be as gross as they can this year they have the poop montage in episode 1
they have the puss montage in episode 2 and
You may have spotted that one of the books that he was giving to Samwell because he's giving him all these history books
He's writing a history of Robert's rebellion remember. There's information that we need to know on the show
We need to know what happened between Rhaegar targaryen and LyAnna stark. That's probably inside that book
There's a little plot bond that they planted now that'll explode in a later episode
but of course number 6 hot pie is back and explains to arya what happened in the North during season 6 o the Bolton's they're
Dead Jon snow your brother
He's king of the north and she immediately almost craps her pants and turns around and goes home
Probably the funniest part in the episode was when he starts going on and on about the night lady did she ever find you in?
starts talking about baking the butter into the pies which is the same speech that he bored brienne to death with when he ran into
Them the secret is is that you got to use butter not everybody does that
Dario Replies with I've been baking some pies too didn't use butter
talking about the frey pies that she's been cooking if we finally get this touching nymeria
Reunion and even though it's Bittersweet
I actually think it ends on a hopeful note because Aria
Recognizes that nymeria is better off doing what she's doing now being in the wild. That's not you anymore
woof
Who is a girl a girl is no one know I'm arya stark of Winterfell so aria is still arya stark of Winterfell
But nymeria is not of winterfell anymore, but she still recognized arya and they had that moment
so if they were to run into each other again in the future
She would probably nod to her and then just run off on her way again
But the really cool thing is if they ever choose to bring them back, and I don't know that
They will because they're kind of expensive they can always bring them back in season eight
I'm not expecting super-Pac to come back during season seven is is they are a hardcore weapon one direwolves by themselves as badass
But a direwolf leading a giant wolf pack is awesome
So number five this is so awesome qyburn takes Cersei down into the crypts
Beneath the red keep and shows her all the targaryen Dead dragon skulls and explains
How they have a weapon to take down Daenerys dragons the ancient targaryen would have had a weapon like that too anyway
So what he did is he just found the research and said okay
They already have a version of this
So we're going to build a bigger badder better version that we're going to use when Daenerys comes marching on us
We just have to acknowledge
How awesome Balerion the black dread?
skull is we haven't been down here since I think season 1 when arya was poking around this was also where she heard Varys and
Illyrio plotting to put daenerys his brother on the throne before he got his golden crown from Khal drogo before the events the rest of
the show
Unfolded but number for Daenerys of small council argues about what to do we learned that they're going to send the Greyjoy south and use
The Dornish to attack King's landing because tyrion is perfectly predicted
how sir she is going to try and manipulate the realm against them we don't want to go in with a foreign invading Force and
We're going to take the true seat of power in Westeros the rock that's where we'll send the unsullied so it all seems good
But the problem is is now they're dividing their army
And they've since lost the Greyjoy's and now we know that they have a weapon to fight the dragons
so they're just trying to balance the scales a little bit and show you that daenerys isn't going to be able to
Steamroll everyone, and I think part of that has to do with the idea that Jon snow needs her alliance
Just as much as she will eventually need it too because they lost all their shifts
So everybody on both sides cersei and Daenerys will need as much help as they can get but number three jon
Finally gets the raven from Samwell so now he's separately
Gotten messages from Daenerys to come to dragonstone and bend the knee and from Samwell saying that you need to go to
Dragonstone because they're dragonglass there
So there's really nothing else that he can do and there were a couple weird
Moments during his big council here where he's trying to explain to them
why they need
Dragons stone like they all love the idea that there's dragonglass of dragons stone like even as dumb as they might be they put two
And two together o dragonglass at dragonstone that makes sense
But even the little bear does not want jon snow to go to Dragons stones
They referenced the mad king killing Rickard stark like I said earlier
They keep likening all these events that are unfolding to events that have happened before during Robert's rebellion in back during Aegon's conquest
But I love sir Davos his reaction to it all dragons. What a dragons have fire fires good for fighting white walkers
She sounds really charming with that horde of hers, but number two
will need boneless pizza
Littlefinger goes to jon snow in the crypts while he's looking at ned stark just trying to find the strength to do what he knows
He has to do and makes his intentions known for what he's going to be doing with Santa
I love your sister like I love your mother. I'm the one that brought her your father's bones and jon
Just isn't having any of it, but I love the look that littlefinger gives Sansa as Jon is riding off for Dragonstone
You can just see the wheels turning in his head like oh
I have to start moving faster and faster because Sansa is sort of wising up to him Jon
Snow doesn't want to have anything to do with them
So the really cool thing we have now is we're building towards an Aria reunion
So hopefully littlefinger will just go off the deep end do something super crazy, and you'll have a stark sister team-up VS.
littlefinger in the next couple of
But number one of course that awesome greyjoy battle big action set piece of the episode of course they're going to smash her fleet
They just want to show you how relentless your on is and he's actually way more evil in the books
But I love the way they make his ships look so much bigger than yara
It literally rammed them then they board the ship using this giant kraken weapon
And he starts going at them with his huge ax with the Greyjoy's sigil carved into it
So who knows where he found time to make all these fine weapons, but he is armed to the teeth
He has this crazy armor on and just mows through the sand snakes, so if you hated the sand snakes
This is probably one of your favorite moments of the episode
But how about that reek scene at the end they've been going on and on about how he's becoming more and more like his former
Self theon again, he's slowly becoming whole but euron tries to twist his mind shake his confidence
And you start to remember the ramsay sayings from the book reek it rhymes with weak as he jumps?
Overboard so now you're on his captured hilarious and Tyene sand and er a greyjoy in
Decimated Daenerys his fleet. I don't even think she was able to take down one of your own ships
But it was a great action set piece way to end the episode so I feel like the greyjoy stuff was a lot stronger in
This episode then the Daenerys jon snow stuff because that's all just still set up for stuff that's happening in future episode so the big
Twist with Daenerys and jon snow won't happen till next week in the following episodes
So they're going to be a couple episodes like that. Where you have storylines where it's just about characters
Finding information and deciding where to go next before they actually do it in a future episode, so let me know
What was your guys favorite part of the episode and what do you think is going to happen when Daenerys meets with Jon snow?
There's going to be so many jokes because people have been waiting for this to happen in the books for so long and even though
It's going to be
Different the way that it unfolds in the books the TV show plot is still written in service to the book plot with Minor changes
For characters that are dead or alive and in different places the thing
I'm really looking forward to next week though is the way they react to the prophecy of the prince or
Princess who was promised it just sounds like something that jon snow would scoff at like he doesn't really think about prophecy
He's mostly thinking about the army of the dead and even to nair seems very skeptical about it
Which I think is actually a pretty natural reaction for the characters
It'd be weird if Melisandre rolled up
And they just bought everything she said hook Line & Sinker so get hype about Davos Melisandre reunion next week
It's going to be great
What's going to happen next is I'll post my trailer video for episode 3 and I'll do a Q&A video on Tuesday
Just like I did last week
There's a couple more comic con videos that I'm doing but leave all your bonus video requests in the comments below
Congratulations to the latest Giveaway winner locum please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
While you wait for everything click here for the latest trailer video that has footage for episode 3 in it and you can click here
For all my other comic con videos. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight